parce que justement quand tu es partie
du chemin elle avait fait vérifier et
c'était oui on lacombe faisait dès son
arrivée elle formule verbalement sa
demande elle se bute immédiatement à la
réticence des médecins se mettaient le
tour notre vue ce cas pas cas priorise
c'est les possibles poursuites
criminelles à son encontre et qui risque
14 ans de prison
et on comprend vite que tabarouette on
n'est pas au bout de nos peines
le médecin m'a propose madeleine lessard
raconte son inquiétude dans son journal
intime
la loi me permet de demander l'aide à
mourir je suis venu ici à cause de cet
engagement de marie claire
samedi le 14 juin que ce n'est pas
possible je vis une grande détresse
trahison l'hôpital marie-clarac admet
que le cas de madeleine lessard a traîné
c'est malheureux que la personne n'a pas
été respecté dans ses lois assez
rapidement marie-clarac est le plus gros
hôpital de soins palliatifs au québec
avec 36 lits depuis l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi en 2015
madeleine lessard aurait été la seule à
rédiger une demande d'être médicale à
mourir ici je suis témoin de personnes
qui désirent notre part a dit pourquoi
les au paradis se déliant n'accapare
fréquent de voir qu'au soulager la
douleur et que l on donne des soins
vraiment avec beaucoup de compassion
beaucoup d'amour et de tendresse les ja
charge donné dix médecins travaillent
ici en soins palliatifs
tous refusent de pratiquer l'aide
médicale à mourir quand on sait que
dalle québec dans tous les hôpitaux il
ya des médecins qui n'accepte pas de
passer à l'acte il y en a un petit
nombre mais je me dis je pense que la
difficulté est là
selon plusieurs sources l'adhésion des
médecins serait moins forte à montréal
qu'ailleurs au québec et les communautés
culturelles serait moins portés à opter
pour l'aide médicale à mourir
marie-clarac a d'ailleurs tenté sans
succès d'obtenir de l'aide d'un hôpital
universitaire pour exaucer le souhait de
madeleine lessard c'est là qu'ils nous
ont proposé quelques tight
on pourrait aller au chum avec mado un
taxi pour le deuxième avis pour
rencontrer un médecin pas de médecins
disponibles là non plus même si la
mourante se déplacer en taxi
madeleine lessard est décédé sans aide
médicale à mourir
le dimanche 29 juillet c'est pas juste
un jeu boudin rollandin médicale à
maurice tru2way profond que la personne
hors du capot pu avoir et on veut pas
que ça se répète pour n'importe qui ici
david gêne-t-il radio canada montréal